[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and today I'm bringing you a statue
that I love the reimagining of the
statue oh and I definitely had to make
sure I got my hands on it pause but here
we go
I bring you sideshows Premium Format
modern Thor now the reason why it's the
modern Thor they have an old G Thor that
I definitely would like to get but at
the time the prices on that statue is
really off the chain it's like taking a
hammer to your wallet crazy right
but this statue oh I got this statue at
a great price from a friend of mine and
I said you know what I'm definitely
gonna pull the trigger on it but I'm
getting ahead of myself let me tell you
why I even like the statue or why like
this version of the statute now I have
many thought statues this is one of my
favorites for the simple fact that in
2007 they had a rerelease is the third
series of Thor so it's Thor number one
2007 and this is after Civil War because
if anyone read the Civil War storyline
the first war Thor wasn't there they had
made a clone Reed Richards had made of
clone of Thor it's crazy right he had
got hair samples and it was completely
unethical they had a fake hammer
everything totally terrible also if you
may notice that the Hulk was not
involved in that Civil War storyline as
well the reason why is those are two
s-type characters prime characters that
will tip the skills in any battle
so when 2007 came around they let you
know that this was not a clone this was
not a robot
this was door after Ragnarok after all
the gods were killed after all the gods
gods died so it was Thor's job to make a
new Asgard and he made as God on Midgard
which is Earth and he had to find all of
his you say dead dead homies he had to
find all of his dead gods and he had the
real waking him so that was a good
storyline but the reason why I
gravitated to it so much was because of
the costume design as you can see it was
a black and silver with the red cape
with some gold trim to it and I saw it
was striking it was completely different
from what I was used to with Thor I was
used to this the og Thor the blue tights
with the red cape and the yellow boots
with the black I was used to that and
this was a very bold dynamic take on
Thor and I really believe that the MCU
design on Thor shaped how we got this
Thor in comic books
[Music]
costume design wise I thought it was a
stroke of genius because it stuck around
you know sometimes you need a little
more pizzazz to the character like
Superman he lost the red shorts and I
thought that was a great design choice
so let's get back to the statue now
after I got this statue this statue uh I
saw it there I said I needed to have it
I was too late to get the e X version
the e x version
with a sword in the hand where our
Millner is and yes see that right so but
the actual hammer itself has the
inscriptions on the hammer I thought
that was amazing I also thought that the
Cape been that it was molded was smartly
designed and has a keyhole in the
shoulder where it rests primarily in the
outward stretched arm and it's able to
show motion in the hair the Cape and the
poles if you look at the poles the poles
is completely dynamic you can see the
grimace in his face you can see him
gripping the hammer because he's about
to toss the hammer you can see the
handle of the hammer actually swaying in
the wind it's a very good design it's a
great design from that standpoint when
it comes to the statute now the base the
base is completely dull to me I didn't
know why he went with steps I didn't
understand I see the wounds signs on the
stone but then again I looked at it and
it's a piece that comes apart from the
base which makes zero sense
so I thought it was a failed when it
came to the base but form and function
it's amazing it's mixed media as well so
when you look at the costume his base
part of his chest his sash that's all
material that's it's a very good take on
the statue
I thought the sideshow hit it out the
part when it came to design and when it
came to sticking to the tried and true
helmet with the wings very old very no
very fundamental and very well balanced
a beautiful statue to look at it
captures exactly what you thought it was
going to capture and it definitely
delivers when it comes to giving you
what I remember from
the book now this is the part in a video
when I'm actually to like follow
unsubscribe and also it's a joy button
hit me hit that joy button yeah I'm
doing it different today I got a hammer
enjoy your button did when you hit the
join button that allows you to join the
realm and when you join the room you get
a chance to win are you ready for this
at Xbox series X hmm that's kind of
crazy we have a giveaway going on right
now at Lords of gaming dotnet and also
the iron Lords YouTube channel so when
you go there there's a ton of ways for
you to actually enter so go check that
out
also listen to the last word with loyal
Cognito any bonta's right now destiny is
in the next season and they're gearing
up for September and if you don't know
what's going on let's say you've been
away from destiny for a long time
just tone it to the last word and
they're gonna get you up to speed
expeditiously well stick around watch
the statue and all this glory listen to
some good music and see you next week
when I bring you a statue that's gonna
make you think out the box stay
collecting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]